[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he is the pride of the chargers back
home in oregon justin herbert back on
the program justin thanks for joining us
how are you thanks for having me again
uh good to be here how are you guys
doing are you in your old bedroom
your you know bedroom you had when you
were in grade school in high school
uh no i'm actually in in the family room
um i've been staying in my old house but
uh
not there right now oh okay so there's
trophies and posters
in the old bedroom um i think those
might be taken down
[Laughter]
you just moved out and they took all
your stuff and put it in boxes
yeah it's crazy no they've been a good
job in my room
together so it's not too bad all right i
got a um
i got a test for you i got a job for you
i want you to take away
one defender that you would not want to
face from kansas city and
tampa so you played them both give me
the one guy if i said you have the power
to remove him from the lineup when you
face him who would that guy be with
kansas city
i'd probably say tyrone matthew and then
levante david
ooh now let me start with tyron matthew
why him
he he just makes plays wherever he is on
the field he's fast he's smart
and he's one of those guys you have to
look out for and coverages blitzes and
he's able to do everything
but when you look at game film um
or when you're you're game planning for
the chiefs like what were you trying to
take advantage of like if you're brady
what would you be looking to try to do
we just have to take what we were given
you had to take a positive yard if
you're hitting a check down for five
yards or
you're getting a run for four yards
that's great you need to be able to move
the ball and you need to be able to
convert on third down
you can't stay behind the sticks and so
that's one of those things that we try
to do and
ultimately we weren't good enough when
we played against them so it's just
something you got to keep practicing get
better at
okay why levante david out of the
buccaneers lineup
just how fast he is and how athletic and
and how he's able to make plays on the
ball and pass coverage and
stopping the run it was really
impressive to watch so what
if your mahomes would you try to take
advantage of
that's a great question i think that's
one of those things i guess we're gonna
have to wait and see
in the supervisor well wait what did you
try to take advantage of
um we just kind of looked at some of the
coverages they played and tried to get
some plays that were
known to work against some of those you
know obviously we didn't end that
win that game either so we could have
been better but
there's just a lot of route coverages
that maybe you can play against certain
coverages
and so it's one of those things you have
to watch a lot of film on and get a good
beat on i understand
you don't want to name names and you
don't want to give any game plans out
and you don't want to face them again
and then have them say oh
so i heard you said you wanted to you
could take advantage of this so i
i don't want you to get in trouble okay
i appreciate that
but you know shaq barrett is uh pretty
impressed
like tampa we don't talk about tampa's
defense because of
brady um but that defense is what
that's that's why they've won their last
two games because of their defense
i think they're incredible i think
they've got a lot of guys up front i
think they've got some really good
safeties i think all across the board
they've got guys and you know they've
got a great coach that that puts them in
a great position to win and when you got
a great coach like that and athletic
good defenders i think you're gonna have
a great defense
we're talking to justin herbert the
chargers quarterback we talked to your
new head coach
uh brandon staley do you know that he
played quarterback at my university
university of dayton were you aware that
he was a quarterback justin
i actually saw some film of him throwing
the ball and i was pretty impressed he
was able to sling it around so that was
that was cool to see he said that when
he was coming back from the press
conference
you were i think the first call that he
made when he was in the car
well that's uh that's awfully nice of
him i i didn't he didn't let me know
that but uh
you know we've talked quite a bit over
the phone and just excited to get to
really meet him in person and
i've only heard great things about him
so it's going to be a great opportunity
to work with him
how would you recap sum up your first
year
if somebody didn't see it and you were
going to explain to them
how you did what would you say shoot
that's a great question
i would say i learned a lot um obviously
a tough year
not the not the year that we wanted
would have loved to have won a couple
more games
but i'm so proud of the way the guys
battled and especially after losing
45-0 at home against the patriots we
turn around and go win four in a row and
um i'm not an nfl expert yet but
usually that doesn't happen and so that
locker room that the guys put together
i was really proud of them what was
different than you expected
um this i think the speed of the game is
is
probably the biggest difference i i kind
of expected that knowing
coming into this level but you really
have to
play through it to really understand how
how fast it really is and
um you know i could hear oh justin's
gonna be so much faster this and that
but when you step out there and realize
it's a lot faster and a couple times
when i drop back and i'd get too deep
and
you get some pass rushers that just fly
around the end knocking the ball out and
you have to kind of go through that to
really understand that it's a it's a
whole different game
what's the uh the hit that you'll
remember from your rookie season
um i think he was on the sideline
against the chiefs um i was running out
of bounds and
i tried to get the first down i stayed
in bounds and i just collided with a
linebacker and
we both fell on the ground and that's
one of those hits that you know i
probably shouldn't do again so i've
learned from that one
you know how to slide you played
baseball you got to get out of bounds to
live to see another play
i know i i got i was
i was getting yelled at all year about
that so i'll be better about it next
year
i i've seen so many young quarterbacks
who want that extra yard
and jimmy garoppolo or rg3 and you just
go get out of bounds
like there's nothing wrong with that you
know what i have a problem when a young
quarterback
can't get up he gets injured because
he's trying to get that extra i
shouldn't be yelling at you i sound like
i'm your dad i don't mean to be yelling
at you
now go to your room justin no i i i
get out of bounds it's okay nobody's
going to say boy justin herbert's soft
get out of bounds yeah it's really not
worth it no get a couple yards get out
of bounds and get down
yes i got to get you into the playoffs i
can't get you in the playoffs if you're
not playing okay
uh how are the uniforms this year any uh
any adjustments to the chargers uniforms
no i thought they were great i i guess
i'm going from oregon to the chargers um
you know i've been pretty fortunate
enough to have some pretty good jerseys
over the years
um and i think the chargers do a great
job yeah i even ask you
better uniform last time you avoid the
rush and didn't give me an answer but
chargers uniforms oregon duck uniforms
um i would i would probably say my since
i play for the chargers now my loyalties
probably
the chargers um that'd probably be my
answer but i've always been
super super happy and
awesome to wear the oregon uniform yeah
but there's so many different variations
on the oregon uniform that
that that light blue that powder blue
with the chargers come on
everybody looks good in that you know
that's that's tough to be
did you get any autographs or jerseys
this year
with guys you played against uh no we
actually weren't allowed to
uh it was one of our rookie rules where
we weren't really allowed to swap
jerseys yet
and so i think that's something that uh
going forward i'll be able to do
well who do you want you you don't face
brady next year do you
i don't think so i haven't uh checked
schedule yet oh no you're gonna miss out
on brady
yeah that would have been cool
unfortunately since i'm such a big nfl
fan
i feel like pretty much anyone i go
against it'd be awesome to have their
jersey so
i'm happy with anyone i guess well have
fun in uh eugene
are you can you walk around town without
people bothering you
oh of course um you know i think
eugene's a pretty small place and
i don't think too many people care too
much about it so
um it's it's been awesome so far are you
having a super bowl
uh yeah we'll be watching the super bowl
but um i think i think we're gonna keep
it to a pretty small
small amount of people that makes sense
uh thanks for joining us by the way do
you root for the chiefs they're in the
afc
or can you not root for the chiefs
because they're in the afc
afc west that's a good point i think i'm
just rooting for a good game
um it's a super bowl and two great
quarterbacks two great teams so it's
just gonna be a lot of fun
to watch for me well good to talk to you
congratulations again
on a great season and uh we'll talk to
you soon thank you justin
thank you thanks for having me that's
justin herbert my chargers